il y ait des champs et à nantes avec
jean-luc passe majan lui pierre grand
mère a écrit dans ouest france je le
cite que la force du désespoir est une
qualité que les spectateurs apprécient
toujours alors à ce que vous avez
apprécié cette maxime à sa juste valeur
jean-luc oui c'était une belle une belle
partie c'est certain que les spectateurs
ont applaudi les nantais à leur sortie
du terrain on peut simplement regretter
qu'il sait concédé ses deux premiers vue
de premier but à ses bêtes d'ailleurs je
crois yves didier là il y a une
explication à vous de demander parce que
pourquoi les nantais prend-il autant de
but à domicile les en ont pris 8 je
crois à domicile contre 4 seulement à
l'extérieur cette saison
oui on se trouve en mauvaise position à
la beaujoire puisqu'on fait de très bons
résultats à l'extérieur
et puis on se retrouve obligé de gagner
chez nous et là on réagit mal on a de
mauvaises positions sur le terrain on
veut absolument marquer et prendre
l'aventage dès le départ est bon il se
trouve que depuis quelques rencontres on
est toujours mené heureusement samedi on
a réussi à revenir mais c'est toujours
très difficile de revenir au score
oui alors je vous propose de voir tout
de suite et bien ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir à la beaujoire donc les
images vont arriver et cela commence par
un coup de théâtre la tactique est
pourtant bien connu un corner une tête
au premier poteau la défense nantaise là
ne peut dégager
et puis s'attelèrent se jette le premier
sur le ballon on jouait ce que puis
seulement sept minutes c'est donc
strasbourg qui à la surprise générale
mène 1 à 0 les nantais vont maintenant
se ruer à l'assaut du but alsacien
de kombouaré sur la transversale manque
de réussite donc chez les jaunes qui ne
parviennent pas à trouver la faille
et puis à nouveau les jaunes à l'attack
qu'avec un nouveau centre kombouaré pour
la tête de robert et là cela passe au
dessus les canaris sont donc toujours
mené à la mi temps par des
strasbourgeois qui vont doubler la mise
dès le retour des vestiaires bad l'ex
nantais pour didot débordements centre
reprise de volée de fabrice med ou
ralentis c'est tout simple c'est une
action très limpide mais j'ai pourtant
bien isolé il prend sa chance et la mare
lô n'y pouvait rien c'est donc
strasbourg qui mène 2 à 0 et le match
poursuite va s'engager pour le fc nantes
52e minute de cafouillage devant la cage
alsacienne verte et or elle récupère ce
ballon adresse une longue passe sur la
gauche
you may bien seul au deuxième poteau et
nantes revient à la marque 2 à 1
débauche d'énergie du côté des jaunes
pour arracher l'égalisation mais la
défense alsacienne ne veut pas céder les
sénans pts et multiplient les occasions
et sur cette balle de hugh johnston
manque de peu la cible
les alsaciens vont perdre mais jean
cours de route le numéro 7 de
strasbourgeois est expulsé par l'arbitré
après cette faute sur kombouaré est sur
le coup franc qui s'en suit longue balle
de vercauteren une tête de kombouaré et
robert prolonge dans le but les nantais
reviennent de loin 2 à 2 et dans les
toutes dernières minutes on a même cru
que le fcn n'allait pouvoir arracher la
victoire quand hugh voyait sa reprise de
la tête frôlait la lucarne cela se
passait à l'ultime minute
alors didier des regrets quand on revoit
ses images des regrets oui mais aussi on
peut être satisfait car être mené 2 à 0
sur son terrain c'est jamais évident de
réagir et de revenir au score
déçus parce qu'on perd encore deux
nouveaux points on en a déjà perdu 11
sur notre terrain ça fait beaucoup avec
un peu plus de chance et un peu plus
d'attention je pense qu'on pourrait être
leader du championnat oui les nantais se
prennent à rêver il dit si ça se passait
bien à la beaujoire on serait loin
devant auxerre c'est certain avec 11
points perdus chez nous et quatre
victoires sur cinq à l'extérieur 4
points ne sera chez nous deux victoires
de plus chez nous à domicile et on
serait leader sans problème alors qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est lié au caractère
de l'équipe c'est sûr l'équipe est très
jeune c'est jamais évident avec est une
équipe jeune et enthousiaste de savoir
calmer le jeu et dans des moments
importants de de calme et de savoir se
replacer pour pouvoir jouer en contre
encore samedi on a prouvé qu'on a joué
90 minutes pratiquement à fond
bon ce match là réussir à le tenir on a
vu que contre saint-etienne on avait
joué 45 minutes très bon depuis les
quarante cinq minutes d'après l'équipe a
baissé
bon c'est pas évident on a du mal à à à
bien diriger nos matches didier alors
didier houi est ce que ça vous surprend
la la le début de saison d'auxerre
je vous dis ça parce que c'est aussi une
équipe jeune et ils sont en tête du
championnat ben c'est sûr lire il faut
préciser d'ailleurs que le nantes a
gagné son seul match à domicile
ici à la beaujoire contre auxerre bat
observe à un peu à peu près la même
philosophie la physionomie de l'équipe
que nous mais bon ils ont peut-être un
peu plus de réussite chez eux ils
arrivent à s'imposer et c'est ça qui
fait la différence je pense il ya de
quoi il ya quatre points qui nous sépare
c'est simplement une petite victoire à
domicile
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'écart entre les
deux les deux formations qui rit oui oui
oui on ne vous a pas d interpeller
thierry j'allais poser une question
alors que nantes est encore condamnés à
l'exploit à l'extérieur samedi prochain
au parc des princes face au matra c'est
sûr que les points perdus à domicile en
obligés d'aller rechercher un à
l'extérieur mais bon il faut se dire
aussi qu'on ne pourra pas gagner à
chaque fois à l'extérieur
mais bon on part au parc des princes
avec la ferme conviction de gagner
pourquoi pas de prendre de nouveau trois
points
[Musique]